Ces choses-là m'insupportent en tant qu'écolo.
Et dis-moi si pour toi c'est pareil
les gens qui jettent leurs déchets par terre ?
Je n'ai rien à ajouter là-dessus
tellement ça me paraît lunaire comme comportement.
Sinon y a aussi les personnes non écolo qui te disent,
non mais ce que tu fais ça sert à rien.
Moi je serai pas écolo
parce que c'est au grand groupe d'agir.
Alors oui les grands groupes doivent agir,
mais si moi
à mon échelle je peux éviter de contribuer à tout ça,
alors je le fais.
Pour moi c'est juste 1 excuse
et 1 manque de conscience de son impact.
Car pour moi
être écolo ce n'est pas forcément faire 10.000 gestes
différents mais c'est avoir conscience de son impact
et commencer par exemple à consommer différemment.
Et si tout le monde faisait ça,
ce serait déjà 1 gros avantage.
Et ensuite,
je crois qu'on part sur le point qui m'énerve le plus,
ce sont les personnes qui te disent,
oui mais tu es écolo mais tu fais ça
après ça va être arrangé à toutes les sauces,
tu fais pas ton tri,
tu manges pas bio, bref et cetera.
Tu rajoutes ce que tu veux derrière, mais d'après moi,
être écolo c'est super personnel,
chacun fait les gestes qui peu.
Par exemple,
j'adorerais pouvoir consommer des vêtements éthiques
fabriqués en France,
mais il faut dire quand-même que c'est sacrément cher.
Donc pour le moment j'achète encore en fast fashion
mais pas de façon.
Fast, c'est-à-dire que j'achète
uniquement ce dont j'ai besoin
et parfois
je récupère aussi les vêtements d'amis et cetera.
Bref, mais tout ça pour dire que
chacun fait ce qu'il peut avec ce qu'il a
et que personne ne peut juger ça.
Donc s'il vous plaît et faites 1 effort,
laissez les gens tranquilles,
surtout quand vous vous ne faites rien.
Dis-moi en commentaire ce qui toi t'énerve le plus.